To illustrate analogical reasoning and
design, or analogical design, we'll talk about a specific problem,
let us suppose we design a robot that can walk on water.
Nature already offers several examples of organisms that can walk on water,
this is a picture of the basilisk lizard, which can walk very well on water and
catch it's prey. Recall that we said earlier that for analogical mapping and
crossword worker row, requires a deep understanding of the source case and
the target problem. That is true here as well in case of analogical design,
we require a deep understanding of the locomotion of the basilisk lizard,
in order to be able to design a robot that can walk on water, inspired by
the design of the basilisk lizard. Here is a model of the basilisk lizard,
this model is sometimes called structure behavior function model.
This particular picture doesn't show the structure,
it just shows the function and the behavior. The function is shown at
the top here, It is shown by it's initial state and it's goal state, and
it's function is achieve by behavior shown here. The behavior is represented as
a series of states, and transitions between those states. We will not talk about
the representations in more detail here, readings given in the class notes
give this sort of representations a lot more detail if you are so interested.